The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good morning,
everybody.
We're on the home
stretch here.
Only two more lectures, no more
recitations, and a small
matter of a final exam.
I should remind you the
final exam is on
Monday of finals week.
And it will be a two-hour exam,
not a three-hour exam.
Same kind of format as on
the first two quizzes.
Open book, open notes.
The difference is that we'll be
giving you some code, which
we'll be posting today, which
we're going to ask you to
study in preparation
for the exam.
And then we'll ask you some
questions about that code.
For example, ask you to make
a small modification
to it on the exam.
And in fact, today's lecture,
just as a special incentive to
pay attention, will be about
things related to the code
we'll be posting for you
to study for the exam.
It covers one final class of
simulation that we haven't
looked at at all this term, but
I think is important to at
least know a little
bit about it.
And those are queueing
network simulations.
From the time of conception
until death, human beings find
themselves all too often
waiting for things--
waiting for events, waiting for
conditions, waiting for
TAs, et cetera.
Queuing networks give us a
formal way to study systems in
which waiting plays a
fundamental role.
Some typical examples might
be in a supermarket,
waiting to check out.
You get in a queue,
wait your turn.
Computers all the time --
you may wonder sometimes why
when you hit your computer,
and ask it to do something,
sometimes it's fast,
sometimes it's slow.
Well, it's because there are
tasks running in the
background that are ahead of
your task in the queue, and
you're waiting for
them to finish.
Computer networks, waiting for
arrivals and things like that.
If you look at the internal
structure of the internet, as,
say, an email hops from hither
to yon between two sites,
along the way, it enters queues
and waits for its turn
to get forwarded to
the next hop.
A few of you have experienced
this when you go to office
hours, where there's a
wait for a TA, and
you get in a queue.
Public transit, analysis
of highway systems.
All of these things depend upon
understanding queues to
understand how they work.
You might wonder why
we have queues.
The answer is pretty simple,
in that it typically makes
economic sense.
As we'll see in our analysis,
when resources are limited--
particularly, say, servers--
it makes economic sense to have
jobs line up for service.
So if you think about a
supermarket, ideally, when you
go to check out, you'd like
there to be no line.
But think about how many cash
registers they would need to
ensure that all the time
when someone was ready,
there was no line.
And the problem is if
they did that, they
would have idle servers.
And so they would not get very
good resource utilization of
the people they would be hiring
to do the checkout.
In designing a system
with queues--
and that's what the simulations
help us do--
we're aiming for a balance
between, essentially, customer
service and resource
utilization.
The organization paying for the
resources would like them
to be working a 100% of the
time at full capacity, so
there's no wasted expense.
On the other hand, it's easy
to show in any reasonable
system that if you have a 100%
resource utilization, you're
going to be providing terrible
customer service.
There is always a need for
excess capacity in a complex
system in order to
provide adequate
service most of the time.
And that's because, as we'll
see, the demand for service is
probabilistic and
unpredictable.
And in order to absorb bursts
of activity, you need excess
capacity, because a lot
of the time, you
don't see those bursts.
All right.
All that by way of
introduction.
If we think about how to model
a system with queues, they're
are all modeled essentially
the same way.
You start with some jobs,
work to be done.
Those jobs enter a queue.
They wait around for a while.
They leave the queue one at
a time and enter a server.
And then they depart.
So that's what it looks like.
And of course, it can be much
more complicated than this.
You can have multiple
streams of jobs.
You can have multiple queues.
You can have multiple servers.
But when we build an analysis
of it, when we build a
simulation, we typically break
it down into components that
look exactly like this and
use that as the key.
As we do this, we have
to look at a number
of different things.
We start with the
arrival process.
How do the jobs appear?
And there are lots of questions
we can ask.
Do they arrive singly,
or in groups?
If they arrive in groups, we say
that it's a batch process.
So if you think about a service
for, say, processing
students at MIT into the
database, they typically
arrive in a big batch in
September, rather than
straggling in one at a time.
We have to ask, related to
that, is how arrivals are
distributed in time.
Assume for the moment that
arrivals are one at a time--
for example, automobiles
entering a highway.
Do they come uniformly, at
evenly-spaced intervals?
Do they come at random times?
If random, is there a time of
day when we see most of them?
We typically model all of
that in what's called an
inter-arrival time
distribution.
The simplest process is where
these things do arrive at
regular intervals, constant
intervals.
We hardly ever see this
in the real world.
Most of the time, we see
something that looks much like
our old friend, the
Poisson process.
Things arrive at a
random interval.
But they are typically
exponentially distributed.
We've seen this before.
Ok.
It is, as you will recall,
memoryless.
described by a single
parameter, the average
arrival rate.
We can look at it just briefly
to see what it looks like,
just to remind ourselves,
really.
So I've just a small piece of
code, where I've given the
mean arrival.
And then I'm going to just have
2000 things arrive at
Poisson intervals.
Why is it not running?
I cleverly rebooted before I got
here, so it shouldn't have
had any problem.
There it is.
All right, so that really
should be--
anyone remember what
this calls?
Right.
And so we'll see that we have
exponential arrival times, a
rapid decay, only a small tail
out at the right in this
picture, and a big cluster
near the mean.
We can look at this in a
different way if you look at
the scatterplot.
And you'll notice that we've
given it a mean of 60, the
dark blue line.
But we seem to have an awful lot
of points below the mean
compared to a very much
smaller number of
points above the mean.
Why is that, in fact, inevitable
in this situation?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because there's
less space for them to--
PROFESSOR: Because?
AUDIENCE: There's just
less space for them.
We can go from 60--
PROFESSOR: Well, there's
less space.
And the reason that there's less
space is we don't allow
things to arrive yesterday,
in negative time.
So the smallest inter-arrival
time is just
epsilon more than 0.
So the time between jobs can
never be less than 0.
And so if we want--
and we're going to have a few
way out here that take a lot
longer, because that's the
nature of an exponential.
So we're going to have to have
a bunch down here to
counterbalance the
few way up here.
We can only get 60 below
the mean, in this case.
And you can see we here have
over 500 above the mean.
So it's going to always look
like that, which is why the
histogram looks something
like this.
So you'll observe that as you
look at these things.
All right, that's the
arrival process.
We also have to look at
the service mechanism.
How does the server work?
Again, we can ask some question
like, how long will
it take to provide service?
And this is called the service
time distribution.
This depends on two things--
the amount of work the job to
be served entails, and the
speed of the server.
So, again, you've experienced
this, no doubt, at the
supermarket, where if you get
in the wrong line, where
there's a very slow person
running the cash register,
even though the jobs are small,
it takes forever,
because there's a slow server.
Or alternatively, you've gotten
behind a line, not
noticing that the person in
front of you has two shopping
carts full of junk.
And so even though the server
is fast, it'll take a long
time to service that job.
The number of servers
certainly matters.
An important question is
the number of queues.
In particular, does each server
have its own queue,
which is what you see
at the supermarket?
Or is there a single queue for
many servers, typically what
you see if you are checking in,
say, in coach class at the
airport, or lining up for
security at the airport?
Which of those is better,
do you think?
Which provides, on average,
better service, multiple
queues or a single queue?
Single queue, right,
is much better.
In fact, it's easy
to construct a
proof why it's better.
Which is why we now see them,
typically, at places like
banks and airports.
Didn't used to be.
Initially, people didn't
understand this was better,
and they would have
multiple queues.
Why don't we always have
a single queue?
Because we may not have
enough space.
So you can, again, imagine at
the supermarket there'd be no
place to put the single
queue for all of the
cash registers, maybe.
And another question we have
to ask is whether or not we
allow preemption.
In some queuing systems, a
server can stop processing a
customer to deal with another
emergency customer.
In others, once a job is
started, it has to run to
completion.
And, again, you get very
different performance,
depending upon whether you
allow preemption or not.
An important part of the
architecture is, of course,
the characteristics of
the queue itself.
The fundamental question
is the policy.
How from the set of customers
waiting for service do we
choose the customer
to be served next?
So a very common
policy is FIFO.
It stands for First
In First Out.
That's the one we see most of
the time in a lot of physical
situations.
Whoever gets in line first
get served first.
There are some situations
where you do
Last In First Out.
Whoever's arrived most recently
gets served first.
A very popular one in many
computing applications is
what's called SRPT, which is
short for Shortest Remaining
Processing Time.
Take whichever job you
can complete fastest.
So these are the three most
popular policies.
You could also imagine a random
policy, where you just
chose some random member
of the queue.
Then there are lots of other
kinds of issues, which I won't
go into in detail.
The choice of queuing
discipline, as we'll see when
we look at the code, can have a
major effect on performance.
In particular, it can be used
to reduce congestion.
We'll often see in practice
this one.
Now, why might that be a very
useful practical method?
Well, It's got one
obvious feature.
If the available space for the
queue is small, by taking the
ones you can finish fastest, you
reduce the average number
of elements in the queue.
Because you get to process more
customers by taking the
customers that you can
process quickly.
And so on average, there
will be fewer
customers in the queue.
And so it reduces congestion.
As we'll see, it also improves
expected service time.
So it is an excellent method.
When we talk about queuing
networks, what
we're going to see--
and I hope I've implied
this already--
is that probability has to play
a fundamental role in
understanding them, because
there's randomness.
There's randomness in the
inter-arrival time, and
there's typically randomness in
how long each job will take
to process.
What are the questions we might
want to ask about a
queuing system to see whether
we've designed it properly?
An important question is the
average waiting time.
On average, how long does a job
wait between the time it
enters the queue and the time
it leaves the queue?
Now, imagine that you're
waiting for
the MIT Shuttle Bus.
How long you wait before you
get on the bus, on average?
You can also ask, once the job
starts, how long to complete?
We can also ask, is the
waiting time bounded?
So this is a different question
than how long you
should expect to wait
on average.
It's, what's the probability
of your not having to wait
longer than some upper bound?
So you can imagine that if you
were working for some company
that, for example, sold products
over the telephone,
you might want to put a bound
on how long a customer would
wait before their call
got picked up.
And you'd do some analysis,
saying if people have to wait
longer than three minutes,
they hang up the phone.
And so we'll have enough servers
that it's only rare
that someone has to wait more
than three minutes.
It's a different question than
how long people have to wait
on average.
We've already talked about
the average queue length.
And by analogy, we can also
ask about the bound.
on queue length.
You can imagine if you're
designing a router for the
internet, you need to know how
much memory to allocate for
the queues of jobs so that
you don't run out.
It's not infinite, so there's
an upper bound in how long
you'll let the queues grow.
And finally, along a different
dimension is something we've
already talked about,
server utilization.
What is the expected utilization
of each server, in
the sense of, what is the
expected amount of time it
will be fully occupied?
Remember, servers cost
money, so keeping
them busy is important.
If we can assign relative cost
values to each of these
things, we can then build a
system that will let us do an
analysis and build an
optimal system--
decide how big the queues should
be, how many servers,
how fast they should be, do
the analysis, and design a
system that meets some
optimization criteria.
So now, we need to investigate
these things.
Two basic methods, as we've
discussed before, are analytic--
and, indeed, you can get books
on analytic queuing theory,
really thick, hard-to-read
books, I might add, that give
you complicated formulas
for deriving
these kinds of things.
In practice, they're hardly
ever used, because most
systems are too complex to
actually model analytically.
So, in fact, today, most queuing
network systems are
analyzed using simulations,
the kind of discrete event
simulations we've looked
at earlier in the term.
All right.
Now, I want to look at a
particular example, and see
how we can build a simulation
that will let us answer these
kinds of questions about
a particular example.
The example is a --
and again, this is the
one that you'll be
asked to look at --
is a simplification of the
MIT Shuttle Bus system.
So as I'm sure you all know, it
runs in a loop, picking up
students, and dropping them off
at some number of stops.
For legal reasons, each bus
has a maximum capacity--
often exceeded I'm sure, in
practice, but there is
officially a maximum number of
people allowed on a bus.
And it takes a certain amount of
time to go around the loop.
The obvious question to ask is,
how long should a student
expect to have to wait for a
bus at a particular stop to
get picked up?
And what should MIT do to,
depending upon whether it's
feeling benevolent or not,
minimize or maximize the
waiting time for the bus?
All right.
Most of the code we're
going to look at
now is on your handout.
I should say I've deleted the
obvious parts so I could fit
it on the handout.
However, we'll be posting the
code on the web today, a .py
file that you'll be able to
study, and more importantly,
probably run it.
All right, let's start.
So, as usual in designing a
piece of code, I began with
some useful classes.
You won't be surprised that the
first class I looked at
was class job.
So what is a job?
A job is --
depending upon the
mean arrival and
the mean work involved.
And I've chosen to model
arrivals as exponential.
work as a Gaussian.
Nothing magical about this.
And in fact, I played with
various other models.
What would happen if the work
were uniformly distributed or
exponentially distributed?
And, of course, you get
different answers.
I said next two attributes.
There is actually only
one attribute here.
And this is going to keep track
of when a job enters the
queue, so that we can tell
how long it had to wait.
And then there's the
inter-arrival, the work, the
queue, the queue time,
et cetera.
And then I'm going to model
a passenger as a job.
You'll note this is kind
of a boring class.
All I've done is say, pass.
Because I'm not adding
anything new.
I am giving it a
different type.
And it gave me a place to put
the comment here, that the
arrival rate corresponds to
passengers to arriving at a
bus stop, and work is the time
it takes a passenger
to board the bus.
There are many other things I
could have done for work.
I could have made it
multi-dimensional, having to
do with how long to get
on the bus, how
many stops, et cetera.
For simplicity, I'm just
assuming that there are some
agile people who just get on the
bus quickly, and there's
some people who are a little bit
slower, who might take a
longer time to get on the bus.
And that's it for jobs.
Pretty simple, but pretty
typical of the kinds
of things we see.
Then we come to the
queues themselves.
The root class is just
the job queue.
Jobs can arrive, and the queue
can have a length.
You'll note that I don't have
any way for jobs to leave the
queue in the base class.
And that's because each subclass
will be distinguished
by the queueing discipline
it's using.
And the queueing discipline
typically has to do with how
jobs leave the queue.
So there's a FIFO discipline.
Pretty simplistic.
It just removes the first item
from the queue and returns it.
Raises an exception if you try
and remove something from the
queue when there's
nothing there.
An SRPT is a little bit more
involved, but not much.
I've not tried to be clever.
You could imagine a much more
efficient implementation than
the one I've got.
But here, each time a job needs
to leave the queue, I
just search the queue to find
one of the jobs with the least
amount of work, and
I remove that.
That's why I'm searching with
the index here, because pop
lets me remove something from a
list at a particular index.
And then finally,
I have another
simple class, bus stop.
And the key thing here what
it's a subclass of.
Initially, I'm choosing it
to be a subclass of FIFO.
Later, we'll see I could make
it a subclass of SRPT, or in
fact, anything else I chose.
But this gives me a convenient
way to decide what queueing
discipline I'm going to
use at the bus stops.
So I mentioned earlier that
SRPT is nice, because it
allows us to reduce the
size of the queue.
I also mentioned that it's
typically optimal in the sense
of producing the shortest
average waiting time.
So let's think about why.
Imagine that we do
the opposite.
This is a good intellectual
tool.
Just think of the opposite.
Suppose we always took the
longest job first.
What would that do to the
average waiting time?
Say we had a job that took 10
minutes and a queue with 10
people in it.
Well, while we were waiting for
that 1 10-minute job to
get on the bus, the other 9
people would each have to wait
10 minutes.
9 times 10, 90 minutes
of waiting time.
Not very good, right?
Now, suppose each of those 9
jobs only took 1 minute.
Well, the first job would wait
0, the next job would wait 1
minute, the next job would
wait 2 minutes.
And even the longest job would
only have to wait 9 minutes
before it started.
So the total amount of
time spent waiting
would be much less.
So we can see that by using
shortest remaining processing
time, the waiting times
are reduced.
Now, with the bus example, it's
a little bit strange, in
that, yes, you'd get on the
bus, but maybe the bus
wouldn't move at all while it
was waiting for that last
person to get on.
But most queueing
disciplines--
imagine you're in the
supermarket--
you don't care how long the
guys behind you take.
As soon as you get to the front,
you get processed, you
get to leave the store.
So in fact, a supermarket
would, on average, have
happier customers if it followed
shortest remaining
processing time, and always took
whoever had the fewest
number of items first.
Why don't they do that?
Or why is not SRPT always
used in practice?
It's got one glaring problem.
What's that problem?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't seem
fair to everyone else.
PROFESSOR: It's not fair.
And this is actually
a technical word.
People talk about fairness
of a queueing discipline.
And in particular, it's so
unfair that it allows
starvation, another
technical term.
Imagine that you're the person
with the 10-minute job, and
there's a continuing stream
of people arriving
with 1-minute jobs.
You never to get your job
processed at all.
You just sit there, and
you wait, and you
wait, and you wait.
And in fact, you wait forever.
In the bus situation, imagine
you're the person who's in a
wheelchair and takes 10 minutes
to get on the bus.
And people keep arriving
at the bus stop.
Well, before it gets to be your
turn, the bus is full,
and it leaves.
And you have to wait
for the next bus.
But people arrive while
you're waiting.
It arrives.
Again, you don't get on.
And you never get on.
This is technically
called starvation.
And it's a problem
that SRPT has.
So typically, if you're using
that as your scheduling
algorithm, you've got to put in
some sort of a priority on
top of it that gives the long
jobs a chance to at least run
once in a while.
And there are lots of different
disciplines for
doing that.
All right, let's continue
looking at the code.
So now we've got bus stops,
which are queues.
We got jobs.
Well, we're going to
have our server.
And in this case, our
server is a bus.
Every bus has got a capacity,
the number of people it's
allowed to hold, and a speed.
The speed has to do with
how fast it goes
from stop to stop.
And for simplicity, we're going
to assume that this
depends only on the bus itself,
not on the traffic.
Not true in Cambridge and
Boston, of course, but we
can't get everything in
a code that we get
through in one lecture.
So it's got a capacity,
it's got a speed.
And then, we can keep
track of how many
people are on the bus.
It's got an enter, which
has to do with
people getting on it.
And does that until it's
full, and then
it raises an exception.
And things can leave the bus.
And here's the interesting
method.
Unload takes a self and
the number to be
unloaded from the bus.
And it just calls self.leave
over and over again.
All right, those are
our basic classes.
Nothing too sophisticated.
As is often the case with
classes, the code is
straightforward.
And now comes the
not-so-quite-straightforward
code, which is the actual
simulation itself.
Probably the most important
thing to understand in looking
at this code is the arguments.
This will tell us what the
simulation depends on.
So there's going to be a bus.
So notice we have
only one bus.
So, again, I've simplified
the simulation.
Instead of having multiple buses
running around the loop,
we're going to assume you've
just got to wait for that
first bus to get back.
Later, we can talk about what
would be involved in having
multiple buses.
The number of stops in the
loop, the loop length.
And for simplicity, I'm going
to assume that the stops are
equally spaced along
the length.
The mean arrival rate of jobs,
the mean work per job, and
then how long we're going
to run the simulation.
Roughly speaking, I'm using
the same units for the
simulation time and
the loop length.
So this would tell us, if we
simulate for 30,000 times, and
the loop is this 1,200 time
units long, how many times
around the loop we could get,
and how many stops the bus
would make.
All right.
And then comes the body
of the simulation.
So the first thing-- actually,
let me write up some
pseudo-code here to basically
show you the way it's
structured.
Yeah, I think we'll
put it over here.
So the first thing we do is we
create the stops, and we
initialize some variables then
we're going to use to keep
track of performance.
We then enter the main loop,
which is essentially while
time not expired.
That has to do with how long
we're going to run the
simulation.
We move the bus.
So the loop will go through one
time unit each iteration.
At least, it looks that
way initially.
So we'll move the bus
that amount of time.
So then, while we're doing
it, passengers will
arrive at the stops.
Then we'll see when a
bus is at a stop.
Has it driven long enough
to get to the next stop?
And when it's there, we'll
unload some passengers first,
and then we'll load
some passengers.
And then, when we're done at
the very end, we'll compute
some statistics.
So that's the overall structure
of the simulation.
Then we can put that in
something outside it that
tells us how many simulations to
run and get more statistics
about aggregate.
All right, now working our
way through the code, the
initialization, while
time less than
simTime, advance time.
Move the bus.
Now, how far we move it depends
upon how fast it is.
So we'll just add to the bus
location however far it's
allowed to move in
one time unit.
I don't care whether the time
unit is seconds, minutes,
hours, days, whatever.
Just it has to be
all consistent.
Then I'll see if there's a
passenger waiting to enter the
queue by checking the
arrival time.
And passengers can arrive
simultaneously at each stop.
I apologize for leaving the
comments out of your handouts,
but I couldn't squeeze it onto
the page with the comments.
Then, here's the interesting
piece.
So we do this.
We're just having passengers
arrive based upon the
characteristics of jobs.
See if the bus is at a stop.
If the bus location divided by
the inter-stop distance is
equal to 0, so it's actually
at a stop, I'll do my
unloading, et cetera.
Now, down here, you'll notice
that up here, I had this
assumption that the speed of the
bus is small relative to
the inter-stop distance.
This assumption is important
because of this statement.
If the bus were moving
too fast.
It might skip over the stops.
Now, this is kind of a clumsy
trick I've used here.
It has to do with
it being small.
It has to do with each movement
of the bus being, in
fact, an integral of the
inter-stop distance so that
you don't skip over the stops.
In a real simulation, I would
have done something much more
careful to deal with
not missing stops.
But again, I wanted to make
this relatively simple.
So I'm going to jigger things
so that the speed of the bus
evenly divides the inter-stop
distance, so when I advance
the bus, it never skips
over a stop.
It's just a trick.
Not very elegant trick, but
it keeps things working.
All right.
Then I'm going to unload some
fraction of the passengers.
Now, again, in a more realistic
simulation, I'd be
keeping track of what's the
average distance a passenger
wants to travel.
And I would have, in fact, made
work two-dimensional--
the amount of time to get on
the bus, plus how far the
passenger wanted to travel.
Again, here, I've done
something simple.
I've just assumed that a
fraction of all the passengers
get off at each stop, and the
fraction depends upon how many
total stops there are.
We can still understand most of
the interesting aspects of
the problem, even with all
of these simplifications.
And that's an important
lesson.
Every simulation is a
simplification of reality.
No simulation is ever a perfect
model of reality.
No model is ever a perfect
What we typically do in building
the simulation is
simplify it enough that we can
get it to work, but not so
much that we can't answer the
questions we want to answer.
And so I've made a lot of these
simplifications, but
they will still allow us, while
maybe not to get precise
answers about the impact of
various things, to understand
how things relate to each other,
the relative impact of
various design decisions.
All right.
If the bus is at a stop, as I
said, some passengers will get
on, get off.
Passengers that are already
at the stop will try
and get on the bus.
We'll have to advance time,
because time starts to run out
as people are getting
on the bus, even
though the bus is moving.
But, of course, even
though time is
advancing, the bus is not.
So we have to model that, the
impact of loading times.
And in fact, in mass transit
systems, it turns out that
loading time is a very
important parameter.
In many urban systems, subways
will spend more time at
stations getting loaded than
between stations, moving to
the next one, if the
stations are dense.
You may have noticed this
on the Green Line.
So we have to make sure
we model that.
And then, of course, since the
bus could be at the stop for a
while, passengers might arrive
while it's at the stop.
Then, we can keep track of the
number of people left waiting
when the simulation ends,
and do things like that.
All right, finally, there's
this program test, which I
won't go over in detail.
It's exactly like the drivers
we've written for other
simulations for at least half
the semester, in which I run
simbus multiple times,
accumulate results from
trials, and then plot
them nicely.
All right, let's run it.
So I'm going to run it with--
I've actually written it
so that I can look at
combinations of speeds
and capacities.
But first, I'll just look
at small combinations--
i.e.
each list will be one.
So we'll test it with a capacity
of 30 and a speed of
10, to 40 trials.
Then, we'll test it with a
capacity of 15 and the speed
of 10 and a capacity of
15 and a speed of 20.
All right.
We have some results.
So what we can tell looking at
Green Line is that I have a
speed of 10 and a
capacity of 15.
The aggregate average wait time
is long and apparently
growing the longer I
run the simulation.
I've only plotted here up to the
first 500 times if the bus
stop at a stop.
But we can imagine that if I
went further, it would just
get worse for a while.
Then, it will eventually
plateau, but it will take it
quite a while to do that.
And here we can see the
interesting thing, in that the
Blue and the Red Lines are
not very different.
So what this tells us is
there's a trade-off.
I can afford to have smaller
buses if I make them faster.
Or conversely, if I want
slow buses, I have
to make them bigger.
And I get more or less the same
average wait time and not
much difference in how
many people are left
behind at the end.
Clearly, here I have
a big number.
These are smallish numbers.
Again, we'd have to run it
longer to see whether these
are stable, and with different
seeds, or different random
numbers, to see whether or not
the fact that this is 80 and
this is 40 is statistically
significant, or just an
accident of this run.
Because we do have randomness.
But we did do 40 trials, so
maybe there's a reason to
believe that in fact, this
is slightly worse.
You'll notice also the Blue Line
doesn't quite get all the
way to 500, which means that
slow bus didn't get to make
enough stops.
It took a long time to load
up, because it had big
capacity and didn't really
get to all of the stops.
All right.
Let's try another experiment.
And let's go change the
queueing discipline.
Go way back up here.
And let's make it SRPT
and see what we get.
Well, we get something
pretty different.
In particular, you'll note that
the average wait time has
dropped rather significantly.
It really has, as the theory
predicted, led to the improved
wait times.
We'll also notice that it's got
some interesting shapes
here, where it jumps around,
goes up, almost a knee here.
And you might try and understand
why it's doing that
as you look at the code.
Is it random?
Is it just bad luck?
Is there something fundamental
going on?
Think it all through and
decide what's going on.
All right, finally--
and, again, I suggest you play
this with a lot of different
combinations to get a sense
of what the code is doing.
So one last queuing network
question to test your
understanding--
different question.
Suppose you were given the
job of hiring a 6.00 lab
assistant, and you had a choice
between hiring an MIT
student at $15 an hour
or two Harvard
students at $7.50 an hour.
Suppose further that the MIT
student could deal with twice
as many problems per hour
as the Harvard students.
Does it matter which you hire?
Well, you could build a
simulation, and you would
discover that in your queuing
network, it didn't matter.
On the other hand, when you ran
it in real life, you would
probably discover that it
mattered a lot, because the
MIT student would answer
questions correctly.
And the moral is, the queuing
network never
tells the whole story.
You've really got to
think about the
thing in more detail.
All right.
One more lecture.
See you on Thursday.